نحن في ضاحية من ضواحي غازية معروفة
باسم إبراهيميلي وما يمكنك رؤيته
ورائي هو مبنى
منهار تمامًا ولما كنا
نشاهدهم ما يفعلونه هو
الاستعداد لما يأملون أنه
استخراج ولكن لسوء الحظ  كان هناك
15 شخصًا في هذا المبنى ، وقد
تمكنوا من إنقاذ ثلاثة ، وظل الـ 12 الآخرون
بداخله كما نفهمه ، وهم
قلقون للغاية الآن من أنهم ربما لا
يسحبون أي شخص بعيدًا على قيد الحياة ، لكن
الأمل لا يزال بعد 36 ساعة من
ضرب الزلزال الأصلي بالطبع
كان الساعة 4:30 صباحًا بارد جدًا
هنا كما هو الآن ، ولذا تعمل هذه الفرق على
مدار الساعة ،
فالخوف بالطبع هو انخفاض حرارة الجسم الذي
تجمد به هؤلاء الأشخاص حتى
الموت إذا كان هذا هو الحال ولكن كما أقول
لا يزال هناك بعض الأمل حتى تتمكن من رؤية
أن هناك حفارًا الآن واسمحوا لي أن
أفتح المتجر لك ، فإن الحفار
ذاهب وفي هذا
الموقف هناك حيث يعتقدون
أنه قد يكون لديهم بعض علامات
الحياة بشكل واضح  العمل يتسم بالألم
المضني فهو بطيء ،
وبالنسبة لأولئك الموجودين هنا بما في ذلك
والدة
طفل يعتقد أنها تحت
هذا الأنقاض ، فهذا أمر مفجع للغاية.